[Musik]
die zweite lebenshälfte nordischer bis
der masse neues zu entdecken und finde
das ist schon gedankt hat man das ist
vor allem im richtigen meinem traum mich
freut sich ja wohl überlegte was machen
wir mal wie die zweite hälfte und für
mich ist ganz klar ich weiß jetzt was
ich habe mir sehr viel ab
das war jetzt lang machen er hat es
tätowiert auf seinen rechten arm
liebevoll villa seien friedlich und auch
glücklich er kommt wenn der tag geht und
tausende folgen ihn fast jede nacht über
250.000 menschen hören seine
radiosendung schütten in ihr herz aus
was macht es aus dass dieser mann
resonanzkörper ist für all die einsamen
seelen die durch die nacht schwirren
das ist die geschichte von radio
moderator alf vicky und seinen zuhörern
wenn beides gehört zusammen und los
danach clubnächten rausch vi
[Musik]
nachtclub heißt die sendung die montag
bis donnerstag ab 10 uhr nachts aus dem
radio studio kommt mutterseelenallein
sitzt als wiki viermal die woche am
kommando pult und steuert seine sendung
durch die nacht
wenn ich da noch roman mache ich sehr
schlicht endlich los papa und mama hat
arid u nicht ob ich mache es immer
wahnsinnig gut damit wirklich da ganz
recht von dagegen ihr wacklig und damit
die volle der welt denen bewohner habe
im nach club fan nadal mit 7 5 immer hat
er ein thema parat über welches er mit
seinen zuhören redet wickel will sie in
bewegung bringen und das gelingt ihm
verblüffend gut aus dieser film
aufnahmen entstehen geht es um liebe und
eifersucht um seine sein
plötzlich will peter bruch einig das ist
thema rhetorik
sie dürfen mir erzählen was sie erlebt
hängt sie plötzlich vor vollendete
tatsachen stand der unterleib sie sind
die renditen auf 08 48 400 4 222 oder
mailen aus studio
treffpunkt 10 dass sie dabei sind freut
doch noch mit dem häufig
[Musik]
drei stunden dauerte nachtclub drei
stunden in denen graf mitglied
telefonanruf um telefonanruf
entgegennimmt
denn der nachtclub ist kein exklusiver
club klein jeder zuhörer kann anrufen
und vor allem zuhörerin tun das auch und
am telefon an ihr an eurer seite
versuchte ich muss vor die versucht hat
und so erzählt ihm eine zuhörerin gleich
zu beginn wie sie ihr damaliger mann
betrog und dass sie am liebsten das haus
der nebenbuhlerin habe anzünden wollen
[Musik]
sie das tröstet bei versucht alleine
sein wenn der tag geht werden die
erinnerungen wach erinnerungen die
manchmal den weg ins radio finden
besucher das stück wie geborgenheit
suchen wahrscheinlich steht kniet
verstanden zwar dass es so hat das stück
weit aber der schutz vor der nacht
mentor bietet und dass sie sich ein
mitteilen dass sie die ente angst hat
dass sie da vertrete
[Musik]
frei sein dürfen mitteilen können in
seiner wohlfühl atmosphäre schafft das
wiki die scharfen kanten des lebens
seiner zuhörer ein wenig abzutragen
das tut mir meiner sache hätten gern
dass du nur freiwillig gekommen
[Musik]
danach schlug die schreckliche sohnes
etwas anders ein original das passiert
dass sie wenn sich host dusche
die händler stufte es wo sie am tag
nicht können ich glaube an tag 1 gegen
die hitze zum die der nacht und
irgendwie so einer plattform muss ja
wirklich gekümmert
in der nacht endlich definitiv tolerant
sie sind mutiger sie sind geduldiger sie
sind weniger scharf als alltags schnitt
weniger nach die schäden zum beispiel
der mantel also die dunkelheit ist
schwer was ich stehe ich wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
ich danke ihnen vielmals dorf einheit
und wünsche ihnen weiterhin das hier so
das motto wo sie zeit und umkehr hin und
wieder auf stoffe sich ein dieb hatte
dankeschön hertie school
wer anruft spricht mit vicky als gelbes
in diesem moment nur sie und die nächte
beschere dabei als gäbe es die 250.000
nicht die landesweite am radiogerät mit
höheren als gäbe es in der nacht nichts
gar nichts zu verbergen
herrlich
[Musik]
die radiowellen tragen schicksal um
schicksal ins land hinaus von menschen
zum menschen die sich nicht kennen
gesicht gesehen werden und die dennoch
eines gemeinsam haben ein leben mit
höhen und tiefen nämlich ein normales
leben wie es hinter jeder hausecke
lauert mit freud und leid liebe sex und
tod
atalanta war
was ist das beste ich würde gerne direkt
in die zwei minuten spiel machen
also blieb dran zu hören ist am tv
im vorgespräch mit vicky während am
radio noch musik läuft wagt sie mit
ihrem richtigen namen am radio zu
sprechen so wie es die allermeisten
anrufer tun das ist nur nach klub sv
20.30 uhr und am tempo an jetzt ist
digital übte zum thema kommunikation in
der beziehung und sie hat mehr zeit
jetzt gehört wer musik sie haben absolut
die kommunikation kam mit ihrem partner
gedenkt dem handy eine klimapolitische
wende im appenzell von da ruft edith an
die zwang ist im januar 13 gestorben
herzinfarkt mit 47 jahren
einfach so editha zum grauen und selber
rausgehauen aus dem leben
diese nacht nur die eine frage wieso
unter nicht gut aber man ist ja bloß
braucht ja wieder kompensiert und dann
ist der vermarkter kommission das stimmt
er ist wichtig sie ist und dann habe ich
dank der jetzt weiß ich noch nicht für
welches projekt ja und er ist so nicht
mehr
die fertigen richtig treffen
solange mit der prinz auch eine redit
führte viele jahre mit ihrem roberto
eine beiz in davos nun wagt sie einen
neuanfang übernimmt das komplett
renovierte restaurant edelweiß in
schwende sie ist aus dem kanton schwyz
hier hochgezogen in eine wohnung gleich
über dem restaurant alleine zwar aber es
ist ihre eigene neue welt jetzt ohne
roberto wenn sie nicht einschlafen kann
dann hört sie nachtclub und als es um
die liebe ging da hat sie selber
angerufen hat diese gewinnen
trotzdem tun wir jetzt
ich habe dank für mich so ich habe ja
den usa sorge hand und hand und im land
kann ich ja auch noch viel auf die waage
viele latina peter bauerin richter und
gastronomiebereich und ruhe gelegt die
sind eh land ruhig nunmehr märz nicht
einmal warum es nicht so genau und mit
selbstvertrauen augen haut es immer
besser kannte wie hast du dich ja viel
ich muss damit fertig war ich weiß dass
das dass meine teelicht aber ich wie
gesagt ein anderer liebte
alles liebe ich bin dankbar für die neue
freiheit und es wird auch nicht
[Musik]
edith hat schon recht viele menschen
sind einsam und die nacht verstärkt das
gefühl während im sommer die eine
zusammensitzen biertrinken würste braten
kurz das leben genießen
sitzen die anderen zu hause alleine
vielleicht hören sie radio vielleicht
den wiki vielleicht rufen sie ihn sogar
an
andreas hat das getan noch keine 40
sieht er seine kleinen kinder nur noch
einmal die woche geschieden ist er seit
bald drei jahren überwunden hatte es bis
heute nicht zu sehr fehlen ihm die
kleinen zu hause oder im auto hörte den
nachtclub beim thema alleine sein hat es
ihn gepackt jetzt am telefon nicht
andreas worden ob ich über traurig sie
sind von trier plötzlich erlag sie muss
ich dir passiert wie anja meister wks
die haben aber keine antwort auf lager
also ich denk wort versiegt das wenn man
gewusst was handy den spürst daran dass
es so weit nicht genau
bis endlich fällt nicht der fall ist
noch immer fremd gegangen und habe mir
sogar vorbei
dazu braucht der ehemalige trotz liter
wie hat das ressort verkehr gefahren
ja
er berichtet
erfurt
das nicht okay
diese zeit braucht am ende so harmlosen
dänen das frauen
das ist das
was punkte sicher große überwindung aber
auch dem eigenen schicksal was to exist
erzählen
was braucht aber wenig aber in dem
moment als wir ausblenden
[Musik]
radio
lid
des völkermordes passte zwischen
russland und island
vorschläge und funktionen in die frau
sie hinbekommen hat das ist worden seien
erstaunt
dann geht sie auch die zuständige
restliche zeit vom 7
was mich am meisten freude das dritte
tor bis zur zellen oft nicht
analytischen der besucher locken wo sie
sich nicht einfach so wurde verteilen
und das ist eigentlich schönsten sieht
rot verzehr eines nur sehr kurz
[Musik]
kritiker halten das auch gut kann aber
kommunizieren
dieser frage stellen haben geantwortet
ziehen sich vom trio plötzlich ein
leichtes ist ein bietet gegangen so sie
honig fließt damit erinnerungen honig
blieben auszogen und glich nach 1 28
glaube verbringen plötzlich mal am alten
bereich fertig machen wir schon nicht
los gingen 85 c mutig andreas ist heute
wieder verliebt die wunde der trennung
aber die bleibt die kinder sind nicht
beim vater
er kann sie nicht mehr spontan die arme
schließen wer ist da sie sind weg nichts
sagen mir immer wenn ich ein kind hätte
wäre dass ich reif sind dann wäre sicher
darüber hinweg aber wenn ich auf meine
kinder sehen
auch seien 2008 nicht vermissen
maschinenraum wenn sie nicht da sind
dass das macht den weg dass ich schon
früh sony kann abschließen das ist ja
das macht das niveau in die maschine zu
schließen
so gehört der nachtclub oft zu seinem
abend ritual die stimme aus dem radio
lenken ab denn alle haben etwas zu
erzählen aus dem leben und das beruhigt
gegangen ist und dann verschieben was
ein trauriger und vergisst eigentlich
und konzentriert sich fast selber
errichten
hundt
ralf wikis nachtclub eine dreistündige
umschau in der schweizer
seelenlandschaft mit einem 54 jährigen
moderator der seine große lebenskrise
mit 50 hatte und nicht einmal mehr
wusste wo und ob es ihn überhaupt noch
braucht ich bin ich glücklich sie zeigen
das fühlt sich die zitate von tellerrand
storch und irgendwie ist der platz immer
toll fand ich keine andere menschen
natürlich kann ich mich nach einem
weltcup wegen dieser sorgen waren zur
mitglieder genau richtig natürlich um
die 120 jahre auf die freundin und er
seit ich wohne ich seit 20 jahren
aber ich habe definitiv ist fühlt wenn
der aufgabe stehen dann müsste ich
eigentlich muss man aber gut aus steinen
die fusion könnte alles im leben hat
mich hat die vierte fanny welle wie eine
salami an der etliche redlich
abgeschnitten und am schluss ein stück
also wahre jeweiligen falls vor mir
nicht ganz einverstanden im fünfzigsten
geburtstag im wunderschönen tag ich bin
relativ früh erwacht am morgen um 67
verpackung und haben das auch die armen
und und um das schöne tag und machen
ich musste ihm leben und dass ich immer
durch die mini stelle jetzt nicht
einfach war das klavier bringt sondern
zu black was ich im lager bringen und
was ist denn passiert jetzt
verabschiedet sich darauf ihr seid alle
gewünschten ziel
[Musik]